i don't see love here claire's journey  from paradise  winter games and the bachelor i have to  say goodbye to you  didn't have a happy ending i lost  respect for you let's  clear that up right now  tuesday october 13th our new  bachelorette player  [Applause]  i don't want to give up because it's  worth it  will claire find her happy ending i see  my husband in this room  the bachelorette premieres tuesday  october 13th on ebc  i don't see love here claire's journey  from paradise  winter games and the bachelor i have to  say goodbye to you  didn't have a happy ending i lost  respect for you let's clear that  up right now tuesday october 13th  our new bachelorette claire  [Applause]  i don't want to give up because it's  worth it  will claire find her happy ending i see  my husband in his room  the bachelorette premieres tuesday  october 13th on ebc